hey tag ich bin max und ja das war
gerade meine neue begrüßen ich fand das
irgendwie cool weil immer wenn ich mir
blut und zu unterwegs bin sagt hague und
so und vielleicht mache ich das jetzt
als begrüßung wenn ich daran gefallen
finde ich möchte das gern mal
ausprobieren weil irgendwie oder du hast
gedacht sagte jeder zweite und
vielleicht mache ich das einfach mal und
ich will schon wieder getan und schon
wieder beantworte ich dabei fragen
ich glaube ich mache einfach meinen
kanal unglücklich so get down crafter
und fragen beantwortet ja internet
freundschaften rethemer internet
freundschaften sind potenziell so gut
wie jede andere freundschaft finde ich
mein ich habe schon ich wenn ich habe
selbst viele leute übers internet
kennengelernt als als youtuber zum
beispiel viele freundschaften
geschlossen
man läuft natürlich faser ich meine
leute können einheit mega schnell können
einheit ausnutzen sage ich mal so ne
jetzt klinge ich in die klinik soll
wieder wie der besorgte vater so aber
ich meine es gibt ich es gibt viele
leute die scheiß machen wir also ihr
habt bestimmt schon mal hier beispiel
ich habe mit meinem bruder früher immer
fünf gezockt fly for fun oder wieder
schießt und da zum beispiel jemand
gesagt er freunde wir sind groß und wir
geben euch neue sachen
wir geben euch ganz viele calls oder so
und dann hat er unsere accountdaten
genommen sowie wahrheiten 19 und hat da
irgendwie scheiße nicht gemacht und
seien aber grundsätzlich kann es so gut
sein wie jeder jede freundschaft wenn
man sich vertraut und so weiter und so
fort
und ich halte es für schwachsinn zu
sagen dass intern freundschaft
schlechter sind als normale
freundschaften mobbing ausgrenzung in
der schule klares thema richtig richtig
scheiße wenn so was gemacht wird
ich finde das unmöglich und ich meine
früher da habe ich selbst mich mal so
dabei ertappt so wie ich scheiße zu
leuten war aber ich habe dann halt auch
selbst erkannt so decker das ist echt
kacke was du machst den leuten geht es
schlecht und so und ich meine davon hat
man kann nicht von mobbing nicht
ein paar leute mal geärgert so aber halt
nicht über ein längeren zeitraum ich
finde sie so was muss man eigentlich
merken wenn ich meine sobald man merkt
dass man leute verletzt dann kann man
das eigentlich auch nicht mehr wirklich
lustig finden und die leute verstehe ich
auch nicht so wirklich
naja product placement mal yaprak
placement finde ich super sache
spaß beiseite gut youtuber finden das
sowieso immer cool wenn sie cash kriegen
aber ich finde auch placement sind in
ihrer natur nicht nicht grundlegend
scheiße so man kann ich sagen es muss
ein bisschen vielleicht der youtuber du
magst seine fans nicht sonst hast es
gibt ja richtig viele coole placement so
hat man ja auch gesehen jetzt was da zum
beispiel alles gemacht wurde zum
beispiel simon hat immer also um
gespielt hatte hat immer relativ
authentische geschichten und sowas und
per se finde ich die sachen als youtuber
finde ich cool ich finde auch als
zuschauer für mich ein schlechtes klar
es gibt einige geschichten die nicht so
glorreich waren aber ich meine das ist
eher die ausnahme
und schon wieder die nächsten 1000
punkten das richtig gut
redner max über hashtags stop wild
island das hätte heute ganz twitter
bewegt ich finde es grundsätzlich sehr
gut dass das man sich als community bei
solchen sachen einmischt die vielleicht
falsch laufen aber ich habe jetzt
irgendwie nicht so den
den sie sich sagen den anschein gewonnen
dass bei der schau der das
hauptaugenmerk darauf liegt halt
irgendwelche tiere zu quälen
ich meine ich halte es für in ordnung
wenn leute wenn leute sich ernähren
indem sie jagen
ich meine so wie ich jetzt aufpassen
dass er gleich das prinzip dass man halt
wie früher jagen muss meint ihre stelle
mir auch wenn man im supermarkt einkauf
das ist ja alles andere wäre eine
illusion wenn man sagen würde
darstellung keine tiere aber also wenn
wenn das so richtig ich finde man muss
nicht zeigen wie tiere getötet werden
pro sieben hat das irgendwie aber
getrübt dass das anscheinend nicht der
fall ist
das dass das gezeigt wird und demnach
ich finde es mega cool dass man sagt ja
ist nicht cool was er macht so als
community und weil man kann ja auch
durch was bewirken ich meine die haben
sich dazu geäußert 1500 punkte fast das
richtig schlag
die haben sich dazu geäußert und es
wurde schon etwas bewegt und das finde
ich richtig stark schaffens vier perfekt
ich liebe es ich versuche als erstes das
schwert weil ich dem hoffe dass wir es
richtig günstig und ja an sich gut ich
bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob das in dem
ausmaße gerechtfertigt war dass die
haben jetzt ein riesenstau abbekommen
also für mich ist es wie gesagt so wenn
man sich selbst ernährt nur dann ist das
in ordnung
durch jagen aber es muss natürlich nicht
glorifiziert werden es muss jetzt nicht
heißen burda werden tiere getötet das
ist kein und so das salz auf keinen fall
sein aber ich meine
an sich finde ich es nicht schlimm dass
man tiere tötet sonst würde ich ja keine
tiere essen
ja das ist sinnvoll rät nur über dein
hater ich habe gar nicht so viele hater
glücklicherweise bin ich auch ganz forum
muss ich sagen
2 und kann sich dachte ich können wir
noch ganz viele extra herzen kaufen
aber dafür habe ich sonst richtig
richtig gutes equipment und wird ist
aber ich den bogen noch eben 30 ich habe
nochmal level gekauft deshalb
wahrscheinlich habt ihr das gesehen
flame 1 infiniti aber ich habe keinen
fall okay ich brauche die habe ich das
gerade geschafft ich habe mich einfach
verlegt und so habe ich dann noch mal
okay ich habe nochmal todes menge
ausgegeben jetzt an ein kreuz dafür
ach verdammt ich will jetzt ein fall
also ich hab den infiniti bogen ich wow
ist das denn jetzt gerade nicht gut auf
damit kannst du auch mal blau mal 'nen
red x max versteht ihr den witz bringt
luca entweder immer aber es war nicht
lokal deshalb weil luca benutzt der
standardmäßig dass herr stecken ich
finde das macht was hältst du von
duschen scheiße ich finde jeder mensch
der dusche sollte sich schämen
und ja der chip ist mein gewissen
meiners höher man halo kann ich wäre
einfach nur zum teil haben
ich will meinen finger bogen benutzen
okay ich hab es vier schwere oder du
kannst nichts gegen mich machen nichts
und ich glaub ich hab sogar noch diese
fire protection geschichten auf meinen
rüstungsteilen habe ich jetzt nicht mein
feld nein habe ich natürlich nicht kommt
schon freunde hätte mir einen fall
gekauft ich habe ja ich habe essen
gekauft stattdessen weil hier überhaupt
essen gekauft
ich weiß nicht ich habe auf jeden fall
möchte später mal studieren möchte ich
später beispiel dazu kommt auch noch mal
ein video das trifft sich ganz gut weil
da würde ich angefragt von der kampagne
zu studieren und so weiter und
fortbildung was ich als relativ
wichtiges thema betrachtung dazu kommt
ein video wo ich dann mehr darauf
eingehen
werde aber ich finde es grundsätzlich
immer wichtig qualifikation ist immer
gut und desto mehr man sich qualifiziert
desto mehr sicherheiten hat man
eigentlich also halte ich auf jeden fall
was davon von vom sich qualifizieren vom
studieren und so weiter
nice dt schade wir konnten leider den
bogen der bögen nicht ausprobieren
aber es war auch gar nicht nötig weil
wir das schwerter schwerter hatten ja
freunde und ich gehe es gleich mit einem
kumpel was essen weil er hatte
geburtstag und ich lad hinein als
geschenk und dann gibt's vielleicht
burger ist es schon zu spät für eine
frage
nein auch gemacht noch mal ein paar noch
eine schnell frage was hätte von den
leistungs in der schule und was sollte
man dagegen machen
man sollte sich einfach sicher sein dass
man auch andere qualitäten hat und dass
es nicht unbedingt darauf ankommt dass
man in der schule gut ist ein guter
mensch zu sein und damit findet wenn man
das weiß dann kann man manche sachen
wesentlich lockerer angehen
aber youtube youtube red finde ich ganz
cool ist ja dies bezahlpflichtigen
modell von youtube und finde ich auf
jeden fall weiß dass man da so solche
sachen ausprobiert ist auch fairer finde
ich wenn da youtube beteiligt werden als
wenn manche leute werbung schauen müssen
mit adblock die kein etwa kam und dafür
schauen andere leute keine gang und dann
ist das halt immer so ein bisschen
ungerecht mit youtube brad würde man
weiß dass viele leute haben dann mutter
haben was gerechter ist auf die
zuschauer verteilt ich selbst hab
natürlich also aber eigentlich nichts
gegen adblock was gibt es in deinem
leben hast du nur unbedingt tun willst
standard frage nach amerika sage ich da
immer kekse halle redet man über deine
guetta und sagt vielleicht im nächsten
ketten wieder okay dann war's das von
heute bis zum nächsten mal macht gut und
schau